You are listening to radio lab radio. W.
N y. S. C. E. N. N. P. E. R.
All right. Okay, so let's just do the
open. All right. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab
and today we're going to be talking,
well, let, let's do it
this way. Which way I, uh,
I was at the 92nd street y in New York
City, a big gathering spot for up, uh,
cool people with new books and that
particular we is Richard Dawkins. Richard,
don't you like him?
Make it so easy for
him? I decided to begin.
This is a real problem for a lot
of people by quoting him to him.
Um, you right. I Dunno if it's
in this book or some other,
the total amount of suffering per year
in the natural world is beyond all decent
contemplation. During the minute it
takes me to compose this sentence.
Thousands of animals are being eaten
alive. Others are running for their lives,
whimpering with fear. Others are
slowly being devoured from within,
by rasping parasites. Thousands of
all kinds are dying of starvation,
thirst disease. It must be.
So if there's ever a time of plenty,
this very fact will automatically lead
to an increase in population until the
natural state of starvation
and misery is restored.
Darwin was worried by the same
thing. I mean Darwin recognize the,
the total horror of the
suffering in nature.
It's one of the things that
actually made him lose his faith,
but he also realized that it's not
just a fact that it happens. It's,
it's intrinsic to natural
selection that it must happen.
And when you look at a beautiful animal
like a Cheetah that appears to be
beautifully designed for something like
a cheater is amazingly well designed
apparently for catching gazelles and
gazelles are amazingly well designed for
escaping from,
from Cheetahs that they are
the end products of a sort
of evolutionary arms race
in which thousands, millions
of animals have died. The,
the shaping, the,
the carving of the shape of a cheetah
or a gazelle has come about through
millions of unsuccessful gazelles
being caught and the successful ones,
um, making it through, only
to be caught later probably,
but after reproducing and passing on
the genes that helped them to escape.
So the sheer number of deaths
that lie behind the sculpting of,
of these beautiful creatures is
horrifying. And at the same time it goes,
it's got a kind of savage beauty
[inaudible]
um, why do you blame
them? This exactly what?
Because I was sitting there thinking,
I know the cheetahs chasing eat antelopes
but wasn't there a nice cheetah ones
that went over to the antelope and
said, here, have a sandwich together.
And maybe something about the Cheetah and
the had something to do with an act of
kindness. And imagine that you see,
I'm thinking that maybe it's not
just meanness that can sculpt,
but maybe niceness can sculpt too.
The exact
niceness as a, as a [inaudible]
[inaudible] niceness as a scout ball.
Ooh, I wouldn't listen to that show.
Wait a second. We are that
show. We should do it then.
Let's do it today on radio lab.
Goodness,
selflessness, altruism. If the world
is so cruel, how do you account for it?
Yeah, how should we think about
it? And when you do see generosity,
how do you know what's really generous?
[inaudible]
right? So we're going
to start the show, uh,
with a story that sort of embodies the
last question you asked about a guy named
George Price,
who is a mathematician we never heard
of until our producer Lynn Levy told us
about him. She heard about it
from an author, Orin Harman,
who wrote a book called the price as
in George Price of altruistic down,
you know, this is a high
school photo. So okay,
so the people on the radio
can't see the picture.
So describe what he looks like. Well, I
tell you, he looks a bit like sort of a,
some kind of Scandinavian
prince in the 17th century.
Good looking guy. Totally. Um, definitely
something about this guy's eyes.
His eyes. Yeah. This was described to
me by a number of people who knew him.
He had a gaze that you sort of
walked away from at your own peril.
There was something that, you
know, he, he sort of new things.
You could start George's story anywhere.
But let's start in 1943 today,
George graduates from college and
he's this very kinetic kind of guy,
really athletic.
You'd swim in the surf and he did a lot
of rock climbing and by all accounts he
was incredibly brilliant and right after
college he starts to kind of bounce
through history. He
was all over the place.
First place he ends up is the Manhattan
project on uranium in Richmond,
so he was working as a chemist on the
atom bomb when he was done with that.
After a couple of years he made a 90
degree turn and started working at bell
labs on transistor research.
Solved some very basic problems there
and then disappeared like a phantom.
Started working at a medical
center on oncology research,
meaning cancer and I remember going to
his lab playing hide and seek all these
bottles and tips to this time.
George had a wife and two kids.
You look under the microscope
at slides of blood and Kathleen,
but he never really saw them that much.
Work 56 straight without sleeping on beds.
Can I remember? He was
always stuff like that.
Gone a lot when the kids
are still pretty young.
You were like five and six
he left his family. Yeah,
just left
turn another 90 degree corner and
began working on computer aided design.
In fact, he invented computer aided
design. He was firing in all directions.
What do you think was driving him
to keep moving from thing to thing?
He just wanted to succeed at any cost.
It made no difference in what field.
And at one point in time
he was corresponding with
about five Nobel laureates
each in a different field.
He wanted to have one great
discovery that would make his name.
So that's, that's George. Wow.
Quite a guy. Very interesting guy.
So what happens next? So next what
happens is he gets on a boat and he,
he goes to London. When was
this by the way? It's November,
1967 and uh, in London,
that's where things, um,
for our purposes start to really
happen by what happens in London. Well,
he starts looking for this question.
He goes from library to library.
There are 13 libraries that he would hang
out at and the question that he finds
for himself, which is weird
considering his personal history, um,
is
why family?
Like why do people have family?
Like, why do families stick together?
There are a lot of
sort of dynamics within the family
where it would make more sense for an
individual to sort of break out.
No, go it alone. I'm like, he
had and yet family persists
and there should be a good reason for it.
He even wrote about the question
to his daughter, Dear Kathleen,
my big paper will be on the
evolutionary origin of the human family.
In most species,
the father just mates with the mother and
she does all the childbearing herself.
But in the human species,
the dominant pattern has involved care
by adult males toward their own children.
Why did our species evolve this way?
Yeah,
it just brings back what kind of a
father our father was towards us and
basically there was kind
of this benign neglect.
Mm. But this question, why family
was only the beginning, uh,
why family led him to a bigger question,
which is why does anybody
help anybody? Huh?
Well, what do you mean? If you
think about, um, Darwin's ideas,
survival of the fittest, think
about what that really means.
It means if you are a creature,
you have two big important jobs,
you got to survive and you gotta
be fit, right? Whatever that means.
Fitness really means how
many babies can you make,
how many babies are you making? And
so if you do some stupid, you know,
harebrained thing, that means you can't
stay alive and or you can't make babies.
That doesn't make any sense. Right?
And yet, wherever you look in,
you see creatures
doing this from bacteria to insects,
birds and and wasps. Fish.
I'll give you an example.
There's a species of Amoeba called
Disco Tealium, discoid, IOM Wa,
which usually the Amiibo
sort of lives on its own.
It's a single celled organism in the
forest. But when resources are low,
what it does is it sends out this chemical
signal and all the other Amoeba who
are also single celled,
they start sending out signals and they
start sort of crawling until they all
meet and they become one slug,
which is now a single organism.
And the slug begins to sort of move
along until it finds a place that's windy
and sunny, at which point it stops.
And the top 20% of the slug,
the top 20% Amoeba in the head of the
slug begin to create out of their own body
a star
which hardens
and they die while doing so.
But the stock allows the bottom 80% to
climb up the stock and to create an orb
at the top of this stock.
And from there all the Amoeba
that aren't, you know, dead,
they can catch a wind
to better pastures. It's like a dandelion.
So what's happened is that the top 20%
have really sacrificed themselves for the
back 80% and that's an Amoeba. So we
figured what the hell is happening here?
This was a great mystery
to Darwin and Darwin said,
this is in fact the greatest
mystery and the greatest riddle.
And if I can't answer it, then
my theory isn't worth anything.
And for a hundred years when people
talked about evolution, this thing,
altruism is the elephant in the room.
So we were curious about
this. Sorry, I'm, I'm,
how might you take this elephant,
this niceness thing that seems to be
everywhere and shove it back into the mean
old theory of evolution? We, it's gotta
be a way. So we called up Carl Zimmer,
who's a journalist we have on the show
quite often and writes a lot about
evolution.
And he told us in the 1960s just as
George Price was starting to ask these
questions, some scientists
came up with a [inaudible]
new way of thinking about
altruism, a thought experiments,
which you ran us through.
Okay. So, okay, so, so Robert,
do you have siblings? I have a sister.
Okay. You have a sister, Sarah. Okay.
Let's just imagine that, um, you guys
are like home from college. Say Okay.
And there's a flood at the crawl away,
which manner and the
water flooding around.
And you can see that your
sister is about to die.
If you save your sister's life and
die in the process, your jeans,
Robert Curology's jeans
are gone. Yup. Yup.
Right. This is the problem. Yes. But you,
your sister a have the
same parents? Yes. Okay.
So your sister has 50% of your
genes, so if I rescue her,
then half my genes survive.
Right? 50% move on. Oh No.
If you had a sister and a brother
and you saved them both lead each
have 50% so it's a watch and so it's
effectively, it's like it's like
saving Robert Kralik in his entirety.
Mathematically speaking,
mathematically speaking. Right.
Can you do this with cousins? Yeah,
actually if you step it back to cousins,
what percentages are, that's a quarter.
In the case of the grist cousins that is,
it's an eight so I have to have eight cut
first cousins to equal my full genome.
Right? Yeah.
Do you have that money?
I have 32 third cousins and that's why
I always round them up at a Rodeo every
year and done and you place
them all together. Your mom,
you guys stay here in case
something happens to me,
but here's what I don't get.
Like how does this actually operate?
Like Robert's not going to sit there
while the manners flooding and be like,
well, let's see cousin, it's an eight
then a second cousin at the 32nd no,
you understand the math has already
been done. The math is already,
the math has been done by evolution on
genes and those are the jeans you got.
Oh, so you're saying that the,
that evolution has turned the math
into an instinct. Yeah. You got it.
I don't think I get it. Like so
what is the instinct here? The,
I know I want to save my sister. Yeah.
Well, so here's how I understand it.
Since this has half your genes and
since second cousin only has a 32nd
theoretically,
your instinct to save your cyst should
be 16 times stronger than your instincts.
No, that's actually roughly
proportionally. Correct. But keep in mind,
this was just an idea.
It's just a thought experiment until our
Guy George Price comes along and writes
an equation, which shows
mathematically how an instinct like
this could evolve. Very
powerful. Okay. So,
well do you want me to just read the
letters? Yeah. What is the equation?
What equals what. Okay.
Okay, so it's a, uh,
w times Delta z equals the
covariance of w I come a Z,
I plus e, we call it e, w. I, Delta, z. I,
no, of course. Yeah. There you go.
Well, complicated. I mean, it was
simple a second ago. It, yeah,
it sounds a little complicated. He's not
just dealing with like a simple setup.
It's like he's got a traits and how
they affect the different groups and how
things change over time. So it's a big,
there's a lot going on in there. Okay.
Yeah. All right.
Do you understand what you
just said? Not so here.
This is a really interesting
word, or we should read it.
When he did write the equation, he walked
off the street into the university,
University College of the
University of London in London.
Completely unknown. Why just moved from
America. No one knew who, who he was.
I went to talk to a professor Smith
and actually showed equation to the
professor and said, is this new?
I felt sure that someone
must've discovered it before
the professor looked at it
and after a very, very
short amount of minutes,
gave him an honorary professorship
keys and the keys to a,
to an office.
Great. One of the best genetics
departments in the world.
So George is sitting in his office,
which by the way is on the site of
Darwin's old house. Whoa. Yeah. And uh,
he's made this big
discovery and he's thinking,
thinking,
thinking philosophically
that what it all meant.
Thank you.
If I can write a formal mathematical
treatment of the evolution of a trait like
altruism,
what it means about the trade is that
that the trait is never really purely
altruistic.
Mm.
If making a sacrifice helps me in
the end or helps my jeans sorta like
selfishness in the skies.
Yeah. If that's true,
the world is a terrible place.
[inaudible]
does. It means that there's no true,
there could never be true
selflessness in the world.
My math means that there cannot
ever be true selflessness.
Yeah.
And I can't accept a world like that.
Why could he suddenly not accept the world
like that? I, yeah, I don't know. Um,
or other things it might be
because precisely because
he had been so selfish for
most of his life.
[inaudible]
and so he decided in his own life to
embark on a program of radical altruism
that would prove that there was true
selflessness in school and that's what led
him to the streets of London
in search of homeless people.
There are licks down and outs and he
began by sort of just walking up to them,
introducing himself a little. My
name is George, what's your name?
How can I help you? It's random
people on the street. Yeah,
everywhere I go I keep running into
down and out alcoholics to whom I give,
when I have anything and with whom
I sit and drink from their bottle.
If they offer me a drink by people's
sandwiches or give them a few pounds,
whether it's by giving them money,
cleaning a filthy kitchen and
then God, Lord, bigger job.
You started giving out keys to his
place, dividing these guys into his home.
People were coming and going.
He was giving them food clothes.
And after a few months of charity
like that, he was out of money.
There was one letter that he had written
to John Maynard Smith and other great
biologist of the era which said, John,
I'm down to my last 15 p and I can't
wait to get rid of the f the last 15 huh?
He thought he was proving
his equation wrong.
So by getting poorer and poorer
and giving away all this stuff,
he was somehow negating the thing.
His math seemed to say was inevitable.
The selfish instincts. Yeah. You know,
he had self preservation instinct and
he was gonna fight the self preservation
instinct and,
and he was going to win to sort of beat
the mathematics that he himself had
written. So he was approaching it
almost like a, like a math proof. Yeah.
Just the red one that you'd be
[inaudible]. When he ran out of money,
George moved out of his apartment and
into this Bandon house in a part of London
called Tomer Square, which one
does the volume for my headphone,
which is where he met
Sylvia. It was rough.
They were just cause they were just
poles holding the walls up some,
some places at balls.
She was a young artist also squatting
at the time and the buildings are
crumbling. You know, people
who had made, makes shifts,
staircases and George
had like a room, well,
a few clothes on the floor. Not much,
but you could see he was always thinking
he would go around asking other people,
does anybody have shoes? They don't
want so and so needs a pair of shoes.
You know, that would be part of it,
but it might also be like
if somebody was sick,
getting them to a doctor because if
you didn't, if you were homeless,
it's very hard to have a doctor. But
like I said, all this is going on.
At the same time,
he was getting thinner and thinner.
The sin neck and then these clothes,
it just hung around him. Hmm.
He began writing letters to his
daughters, apologizing, weeping.
Dear Henri, sorry,
I deserted you like that and I'm sorry
it was such a poor father to you. Yeah,
I've been a terrible father.
Looking at your picture now makes me
wish I could do it all over again.
Maybe where I come into the
picture is to leave you.
And then he wanted to
begin again. She says,
George asked her to marry him over
and over for us. I thought it was, um,
kind of a joke and I was Saint
George, we can't get met, you know,
she said no each time and that
at a certain point he gave up.
It's hard to really, really remember,
but it was cold or is
it as a winter came on?
Um,
okay.
You wouldn't see George's often.
He became quieter. I think.
I just remember, um,
I'm quieter. One morning,
this guy that was sharing a squat
with George name is Shmuley Katia.
He was heading out the door.
He found beneath the door. Um,
as he was going out of the building,
he found beneath the door a letter.
And since they were living in a squat,
he was afraid that this was some kind of
eviction notice or something like that.
He didn't read English,
he couldn't read English.
So he ran up the stairs and knocked on
George's door because George was the only
one who could read English.
And when he knocked the door,
sort of kind of went in a bit and
he could see in the aperture that,
that there was blood all
over the linoleum floor.
Money had enough of an opening.
He could see that George was sitting
there with no blood left in his body.
He killed himself. Yeah.
He took a pair of, um,
of scissors and cut through his
carotid artery, which is a very,
very sort of terrible death.
[inaudible]
oh,
thanks to producer Lynn Levy
for more on George Price,
be sure to read Oren Harmon's
book, the price of altruism.
And thanks also to Carl Zimmer. His
latest is microcosm. We'll be right back.